ok les garçons emportez
ça c'est résident ils viennent de quitter la balise bon
ça ne va pas être trop long ça va être un
gros gros succès et j'aimerais rencontrer
un américain ne veut-il pas vous rencontrer
c'est est-ce que ça
me pardonne  ne pas se lever ma femme
Ellen ça te dérange si je t'appelle
Elizabeth non
je pense que s'il te plaît arrête de bégayer c'est
juste une de ces choses qu'est-ce que ça
fait ici nous n'allons pas servir
le roi et la reine d'Angleterre au
pique-nique des présidents White  a organisé que des
hot-dogs soient servis comme plat principal permettez-
nous ensuite de mettre un peu de moutarde pour
vous vous allez être un très bon roi
s'il y a une guerre l'Amérique pourrait être
persuadée d'aider je serai là
sans aide  de nous Daisy
ne sera peut-être pas bientôt en Angleterre pour être le roi
de nous
ils ne voulaient pas de moi comme leur parent
je ne savais pas qu'ils avaient voté pour ça en
Angleterre
toi